foreign
[Music]
for a very special debt free scream
uh Cindy are you with us
yep Chuck and I are both right here
hey Chuck I know you're not speaking to
me right now but I just want to tell you
hello so uh Cindy reached out to our uh
Ramsey concierge team and so did Chuck's
hospice nurse uh asking to as a hospice
wish to uh to do their debt free scream
and that's how we got introduced to
Chuck and Cindy over the last couple of
weeks here around Ramsey and then got it
set up with Austin our associate
producer to do your all's debt free
scream today so uh Cindy let's start off
with how much debt you've paid
so we've paid off a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars and it was mostly just
mortgage stuff
um we had paid off some other stuff
after Chuck uh while Chuck was in
Afghanistan
um but we had paid off when we started
the Ramsey plan we paid off our mortgage
so you paid off your mortgage 120 000
how long did that take
about 75 months excellent excellent and
Chuck was in Afghanistan with the
military
he was he was what they call a dirt
sailor he was a Navy guy in the um
Afghanistan Arena as a basically a
middle manager because they didn't have
enough apparently so well thank you
thank you for your service Chuck we love
you we appreciate you all right now tell
us your story of how we get to this call
today and what's been going on with you
and Chuck
oh I'll try and do it without crying
um
with
um terminal brain cancer called a
glioblastoma and
um
prior to that we had you know we had
been debt free and we're living our
lives and we're so happy enjoying our
lives
and
um when he got sick
one of the things that I um
that I was so grateful for was that we
were definitely on the Ramsay plan
because I didn't have a mortgage that I
had to stress about paying off or paying
at all like no mortgage payment we had
no Consumer Debt and we had
our
we had six months worth of expenses set
aside and when he first got sick
I sold my car and
um our little pop-up camper in order to
move that to 10 months worth of expenses
of our normal expenses so
um
so that has that what a relief I mean so
let me get my timeline right so you were
debt free mortgage and everything before
June of last year
yes okay so you're a little you're a
little late to do your debt free scream
here but of course we got you on the
phone anyway right but so yeah so you're
a hundred percent debt-free house and
everything and how old are you
um we are 55 and 56. okay and that all
happened and then he gets his diagnosis
yep in June yep okay yep
and uh and so since June we've been
fighting terminal brain cancer
yep wow
yep one day at a time and filled with
gratitude amen
amen uh but he he uh expressed to his
hospice nurse that he didn't ever do his
debt-free scream when he paid off the
mortgage and that was one of the things
he wanted to do
yep yeah he's not in his head
so what was this process like for you
guys as you attacked the mortgage
so
um we were probably a little different
than most other people because
we we did all of ours with
um
I'll say budgeting you know we were just
really way more attentive to the budget
um we had taught Financial Peace
University six times and each time we
were able to kind of look at our budget
a little bit differently with a slightly
different perspective and
um so we you know we we used our income
to pay down the mortgage and you know it
was basically an extra thousand dollars
a month or if there was you know
something else left in the budget at the
end of the month we're like okay well
let's throw that to the mortgage too
um you know because every Dollar's got
to have its name so you know we just
kept throwing any extra money that we
had in the budget towards the mortgage
okay
um
people often
say I don't want to work this get out of
debt plan I need to live my life because
life's short
and today we're talking about life being
short and yet you all you all sacrificed
to be debt free do you regret doing that
instead of spending all that money doing
something else
so no because we really lived our life a
lot I mean we went I mean we may have
gone camping instead of a four-star
hotel but we went places we traveled we
lived Our Lives we probably spent more
time doing some of those things that
people say oh I can't wait until I
retire and I can do whatever we really
focused on living Our Lives before he
got sick yeah and before you got the
house paid off even but then you're
still intentional with the budget and
dialed it in a little more every time
you taught FPU and still got the house
paid off yeah I just want I just want
because sometimes uh
it's uh
I have never talked to anyone in 30
years of doing this that regretted
the sacrifice of getting out of debt
like they missed something because they
did that
you know what I'm saying no wait oh I I
agree wholeheartedly it has been the
biggest gift through all of this
um I actually I sent an email a while
ago to you guys and it it
it went through you know all the
different filters and said fill out this
form and I was like ah too much work
um I was a little lazy but um basically
the title of my email was thank you for
saving our bacon because truly if it
hadn't been for the Ramsey program I am
not certain
you know that I would have been able to
literally I just I walked out of work on
Thursday afternoon and um he had a
seizure on Friday morning and I never
went back never looked back was knew
that we'd be okay
yeah because because of the FPU program
and he I mean he's uh he's a good man
and he knows that you're going to be
okay
that is one of his biggest concerns was
he just wanted to make sure I would be
okay
yeah and you are
yep yep other than a broken heart which
I got with you and I'm trying to get
through this without crying too
sorry so we're barely be a blubbering
mess here together Chuck I'm just saying
buddy oh man so mild what what's your
financial situation look like now
with him being in hospice and you're not
working
so um
the VA has stepped up
um there's a whole lot of behind the
scenes and if anybody wants that
information I will be very happy but
between his work disability Social
Security disability and the VA
disability as well as the VA paying me
to be his caregiver
um we are
we are we are fine we are absolutely
fine yeah good good I'm glad to hear
that hon
well Chuck you're a hero man you served
your country you served your wife
and um
we are honored to do
a debt-free scream with you today
um
Pretty stinking incredible
all right Cindy you guys ready
are you ready Chuck
okay all right Chuck and Cindy Raleigh
North Carolina a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars paid off house and
everything count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
weren't that free
we're a little quiet
as it should be
that's how it's done
man oh man oh man oh man
wow
thank you both so much what a special
call I wanted to be a part of it amen
wow
this is the Ramsay show